guys can we talk about hats we're all
wearing hats we are yeah what are you
advertising i don't know i don't know
it's just the hat um
i'm not advertising them
that was a dick
yeah
oh yeah oh yeah
i'm showing support yeah no it's good
it's smart you should have a question
about hats
i've been i've been i've been wearing i
think the the listener would find or the
watcher would find this uh more
interesting than the than this than the
uh
the episode i know i do i don't know why
um just general conversation about
things like hats been the sunny episode
yeah the sunny episode's hilarious yeah
i haven't i'm not commenting on getting
into that yeah i just don't
talk the talking about i've i've noticed
that i'm having the most fun when we're
just talking about hats or things of
that one
yeah yeah
i like the balance there's a good
balance because i
i do like when we start
going in depth in terms of what we were
thinking about why we made a choice that
we made and i think that's interesting
for the listener this is why the show
works i have an idea you're like i don't
like that let's do this other thing and
you're like i see validity in both of
those let's just see how it goes and
then we just kind of find a happy medium
yeah but that's what i just said i said
i see
validity you indicated to him but that's
because that's because we've had this
conversation before and and that's and
that's something i've said to you
no what about hats what about yeah
okay so i i um my whole life i've worn
hats but i've turned the bill the way
that you're yours is right yeah and so i
started seeing people wearing the flat
bill and i thought i don't know i don't
know if i can pull that off but i do
think it looks cool i see charlie
where's he's not wearing one today he
can do it either he can
and i think it looks pretty cool now i
don't know if it looks cool because it
seems like we're like 25 year olds like
trying to look and is it sad maybe that
a 44 year old is going to wear a flat
brim hat seems like a young person's
game i'm not sure but i do like this hat
is this what your is this the question
are you wondering i'm wondering can i
pull off because i have now have i've
now noticed that i've gone out and
bought a couple of flat build hats and i
enjoyed them can you take your your
headphones off for a second i like the
five build hack i think it's a head
shape thing i i think yeah no i think it
looks good um
it doesn't i can't do i can't do it my
head is very oval shaped
so when when i do the flat brim thing
it's too the whole thing's too round so
it like presses into my temple i can't
can i see this on you
sure let's see if i've got it because
i'm gonna have plenty out because
there's one hand caitlyn says the same
thing and then she'll put on a hat like
that and it looks cool
this is uh okay see that looks cool to
me now he can do you can do you can do
that you can make that work i think the
thing with with with fashion in general
it's just about the confidence of the
choice
you know you're going all the way look
at my man jonah hill out there yes
wearing whatever the hell he wants and
by the way it looks great he looks great
the more like the more sort of out yeah
i'm sorry he needs something yeah
sorry i know glenn i think you can wear
that flat hat all day in fact i think it
looks really good
the flat you like the flapper okay yeah
i kind of wish you were taking a picture
yeah i don't know it's never it's not
that actually maybe the trick is that
i'm trying to maybe i'm making the hat
too tight
because that was a little loose on me
and that felt good but then that always
feels goofy to me because it seems like
there's too much room on the outside
you know what i don't have confidence to
do but i think they look great
is like the full on
like
bob dylan sort of like half cowboy half
fedora hat you know
like the real hipstery kind of just like
strong whatever hat choice you make you
pull off
sunglasses and hats they all look good
on you
well you know i think it's just the hat
itself looks good right and so i just
chose to wear it but you know what i
mean i think that's what i'm saying your
head shape it's looking good yeah she
got a good you got a head and a good
face shape for glasses and sunglasses
i've noticed i don't know i'm sure
there's plenty of hats and sunglasses
that would not look great i'm noticing
that uh there's a trend that there's a
lot a lot of compliments being thrown in
charlie's way on this podcast let's get
glenn some compliments no no no no no no
that's not that's not what i'm asking
for that's not what i'm saying that's
true like yesterday you guys were saying
that i was very athletic and i was
thinking you guys are athletic
there's something you know i don't know
yeah you're just i just it's just
something i've noticed it's okay okay as
you were you know i'm a jack of all
trades and hats
and uh
that's athletics
sunglass athletics
but you dabble in a million things a
million more than i do
i feel like i get very very good at like
a couple things versus you do
yeah
i do a lot of things not that way
average yes like i'm kind of okay
i think it's the term it is yeah yeah i
don't know what that word is
if i'm being honest i don't know what it
is it's like somebody who um
has a lot of like passions but isn't
serious about any of them yeah yeah yeah
i'm very serious in the moment and then
and then i'm done for the day and i'm
like great i'll do that tomorrow and
then i don't but then i pick it back up
two weeks later and i'm like not that
good i don't think i don't think you are
that i think you you you
really learn and get into things and and
know a lot of stuff and glenn i love
your hat thanks man
[Music]
should we talk about this episode um i i
thought it was pretty funny i don't
remember this being the second episode
of the third season i don't know why but
for some reason this is we shot it much
later and i think we liked it and pulled
it up or something well a lot of the
scenes were shot in philly yeah for sure
but that was at the end
which was at the end of our shooting
schedule usually so yeah did you guys
notice something um
that so
we we have a thing now or we had a thing
then when we would have like two or
three scenes before the episode started
and then we just started instead of one
single scene so there's like one there's
like two scenes there's the there's the
scene in the bar where we're all arguing
like crazy and charlie screams then we
go outside yeah right then we come back
for essentially a third scene after um
back at the bar back at the bar where
we're actually talking about what we're
gonna do and we then at some point just
skip past that and now we just have
somebody come in in the cold open and
say okay the episode's about to start
because we're gonna go try out for the
eagles but we you don't know that we're
gonna try out for the eagles for for a
very long time yeah for longer than it's
unnecessary
um is that arguing was that a sort of
self-aware meta
yes like answer to like a criticism of
the show isn't it funny that we like
what like 8 10 15 episodes into doing
our show or like well we better comment
on what we're doing like yeah just
self-reflecting constantly uh but i do i
do appreciate that we doubled down so
people like ah it's the show where they
just yell at each other it's so annoying
and we're like you know what let's start
an episode where we're screaming at the
top of our lungs let's acknowledge it
and then keep doing it
really lean into it yeah yeah uh one
little thing i completely forgotten
about this episode which i enjoyed so
much was the capes
oh yeah
people were drawing wearing capes and i
had no recollection of the guy with the
lunch box
yeah he was whose mom made his tape who
was [ __ ] great yeah yeah who was that
guy he's an actor yeah i don't know
i don't remember he killed me
and when uh i'm i'm just talking about
the things i like this is not really
interesting philip knew commenting
okay
yeah
it says
assuming
i remember him being now look maybe i'm
wrong can you look it up meg and if not
we'll cut that cut that got that i think
he was legally blind yeah i think so i
remember him saying like on day one he's
yeah yeah
i can't really see and we were like
right well you should definitely um come
join us like that's such a fun character
trait for someone trying for the eagles
yeah right to not be able to see he was
so funny his mom made him a cape faze on
love is hilarious in the episode
do you guys remember faison i i every
time i see faison in something i'm like
why is this guy not a massive movie star
i know
yeah i think i know why too maybe i
don't know i don't know if this trend
like you know
like sort of carries through his entire
uh acting career but
i'm sure you guys remember this that the
very first day that we shot with him uh
it's not the first scene that we see him
in because that was actually in philly
so that was much later the very first
scene that we shot i believe was the
scene where he calls us all over
and he you know gives us the speech
right before he introduces uh donovan
mcnabb
and the speech was so long this was like
it was like a page and happened it was
really funny yeah it was really funny
we're really looking forward to seeing a
lot of time crafting this really funny
like speech that he gives to everybody
and
faison so the way the way we do things
and
not a lot of shows do this but but uh
what we always do is the very first
thing we do
is we just read the scene we get
together with all the actors that are in
the scene we've got what's called sides
which is just a small version of the the
scene in script form
and you we just read it first before we
block it
well so we show up to uh to do this
scene we're outside we've all got our
sides and we're all standing around
except i noticed that faison didn't have
his sides and i was like oh wow
this guy's like a maid this guy's a pro
he's off book as they say in the
industry he's already off book and
normally you're not off book by that
time you know you but i was like man
he's it's a big it's a big speech he's a
big speech he must have really memorized
monday morning he took the whole weekend
right exactly so we show up he you know
we gather around for rehearsal faison's
there you know we're all looking around
and uh you know savage calls action he's
like action
nobody says anything and uh and we're
like oh uh faison that's you and he's
like oh
and we're like
go
he's
does anybody have any sight he's like
what do you want me to say what do you
want me to say
so not not only did he didn't read it
not right he didn't even not entirely
certain he read the script oh he
definitely didn't read the script you
know uh uh
no way showed up to the rehearsal
not knowing his lines and didn't even
have the sides to prompt his lines to be
very clear it's not it's not a rehearsal
like a week before you film it's
the rehearsal is just right before you
say action and actually roll the camera
pretty much yeah you've got maybe 15
minutes between the time you rehearse
yeah the 15 minutes they light it and
then you're shooting and adjust your
shirts and then yeah make sure your
microphone's in your shirt and we're
like oh no oh no this guy's got a page
and a half long speech he's like we're
screwed
and he and we were and he didn't know it
and he just improvised a bunch of stuff
and we cut it you know down to that
little short thing that's in the thing
yes that's in the episode yeah yeah
and it got blossomed and it totally
worked i mean that's the thing is like i
think that he's and also he's so lovable
and fun and he was really cool it wasn't
like he was coming in to be a dick he
was just like island's the way i do it i
think there was also a conception that
we were an improv show yeah i think
people thought we were just like
yeah
here's a scenario let's make up a scene
yeah uh which we were definitely not we
weren't boy that would be really funny
if he thought that
uh did we hire him we just made an offer
to him we just made an offer yeah we'd
seen the movie made
yeah and elf and i mean
we're like this guy's great and it turns
out yeah it it
he's one of the funniest parts of the
episode i mean he's amazing it's
absolutely it absolutely works he's just
doing his own thing and we were like
great there is oftentimes a thing where
like
we scripted a whole thing and you do
realize oh i don't need any of these
words i just need the essence of what
these words are trying to get after her
which he sort of embodied which is just
like i just need the energy right and
the intention and one sentence can cover
this entire speech by the way by the
time he introduces donovan
and jeffrey jeffrey comes out and does
that commercial i mean i was crying too
yes jeffrey's laughing amazing and
that's why we've used
year after year after year
uh across shows i mean i've used them on
mythiquest a number of times
we put him in a pilot years ago yep
we've had him play multiple characters
on uh and it's always sunny although
always as jeffrey owens or this
mysterious man who we don't know he's
also played
tiger woods that's what i'm saying yeah
yeah he's played
but it's always the same actor
who presumably is jeffrey owens although
he he never fesses up to that either
because he never fesses up to actually
having been uh what was it al elvin on
on the cosby show
but one other thing i wanted to bring up
about faison
i'm sure you guys remember that no of
course you do because we've joked about
it many times
the man could not say the words donovan
mcnabb yeah donna john the crab
daddy in the crab
johnny the crab donut not a big football
fan i think faizon
i guess not yeah i guess not but just by
the way that is a difficult name to say
donovan mcnabb i'm having a hard time
saying not that hard i'm on pain
medication though so i have an excuse
but that's just the name
of in mick nab yeah yeah slow it down if
you need to just yeah
but he would just if you watch the
episode please please watch the episode
and watch how he pronounced it because
he never got it right we could go back
and get the we could get the outtakes it
might be worth like putting that out
there because i don't think i don't
think we put it on like a real or
whatever
donny john crap mccrabb johnny john
mccrav donovan donovan i think in the
episode he called him donna donovan
donovan mcmahon
dominar
yeah the one that's that was the closest
now a professional doesn't matter it's
still so it just doesn't it's kind of
better that he doesn't say the real name
because then it's sort of
it's almost implied that he's like not
legally allowed to call this man donovan
mcmahon because he's not jonathan mcnabb
right so he's going to dance around it
yeah
[Music]
one thing we do in this episode that we
then go on to do a number of times and
we've kind of gotten away from it um i
think and probably in a good way because
it dates the episode in a weird in a
weird way where we are referencing like
popular culture like movies that had
come out
yeah talking about invincible yeah and
yet like you know the way that movies
kind of come and go
nobody knows that movie anymore but our
since the show's continued on people
might go back and watch these episodes
and you have no idea what we're really
talking about it's pretty funny that
we're talking about it as the new kids
on the block movie yes i do like that i
do like that and not only do we
not only do we refer to it as that but
faison refers to it yeah because of the
new kids on the block movie yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's right that's why
they're having to do it because they're
getting so many yeah they got badgered
into it because that was the part of the
movie right like they had a tryout and
then was that based on that that was
based on a real thing right now yeah
i admit i never i actually never saw
that movie
yeah i did not not even when we were
writing the episode i didn't even watch
it i should have i did just didn't it's
like it's rocky in
a football but but it was based on a
real story yeah okay now so do you know
the story i do but it's not as it's not
as
the guy vince papali was a player
was like a track star so it wasn't like
some like rando guy from the
neighborhood he was just older and then
it turns out he was like can you believe
it he was 31 years old but i mean did
was there did the the eagles hold a
tryout yeah they they do their oh they
do that yeah every nfl team still
continues to do a version of it they're
just [ __ ] random yeah the whole like
open tryouts yeah they're like just in
case
you know there's a farm somewhere and
there's a dude working in the barn and
he's 7-7
380
and he he's the fastest runner in the
world they're just hoping that that guy
shows up he was just too stupid to
realize that football existed because he
was kept he had a stroke he had a strict
maddie right and he was like
football but we need you here on the
farm
and then what's football daddy
enough about football his daddy played
football but he didn't make the the
cowboys and he was heartbroken he's like
i just and then when the sun makes the
team he was just like i just didn't want
you to go through the heartbreaks on
you know but then but then the guy makes
the team but then his heart explodes at
28 years old yeah because he has thyroid
problems
right because he's seven foot seven i
mean didn't we just establish that i'm
going along with what you said yeah yeah
okay yeah he's got a thyroid issue
um
vincent papaleous
yeah vince papalia papalia oh
do you remember uh the refrigerator
perry of course oh yeah he played for
the bears but then also the eagles did
he play for the eagles yes i remember
him on the bears yes yeah just so big he
could just run over everyone i remember
the the he scored like a huge touchdown
that that one in the super bowl in the
super bowl right the patriots versus the
um the chicago bears yeah and
the pats lost like it was like 60 to 36
10 or something like that oh lord no it
was like sixty to three
look up what that was uh what year was
that it was a beat down there you go uh
patriots bears super bowl 1986.
85 season 86 wow
wow
i mean like 46 10.
46 10 46 10 yeah i have a weird thing i
feel like that's what i remember like
football scores i feel like that's
exactly what you said i dramatized it
you sure did well because it was
exciting
it was a beat down i think that it was
actually worse than the score yeah like
i think they kind of let them
score at the end they just didn't care
i just gave up
ouch yeah you know what we gave up on
completely forgot about the character of
doyle mcpoyle yeah
i did not remember there was a doyle
mcpoyle yeah there's a door maybe he
died from that that bullet wound
i i was laughing so hard at you laughing
because this is all happening in the
moment where they're just walking out of
the um
walking out of the rv and you're
commenting on each one of them as they
come down and you but you're seeing them
for the first time in real life oh no
that was like yeah
i was like literally laughing as he's as
he's doing it but it just works it works
as a character yeah yeah yeah yep that's
you're out here yeah you're in the world
yeah yeah oh good you brought your fife
yeah actually is that a jar of yeah oh
yeah what is that a jar of
but once again the props department
doing like an amazing job of like
putting together a group of weird things
and then you're not seeing them until
you're seeing them yeah for the first
time
even just the coverage of that though i
kind of was like oh right we really
stopped down to see all those people
come out yeah
which i feel like maybe we wouldn't do
now but maybe we would did we play the
hawaiian uh the mcpoyle hawaiian theme
song yeah uh
yeah every time i'm on here pretty much
every time we see the coils
yeah we play this uh this like
hawaiian cowboy yeah hawaiian cowboy is
that the name of the song hawaiian
cowboy
i feel like it's something maybe it was
just like it was a you know there was
this library of cheap music that
we could use and uh it was probably
listed as hawaiian cowboy or something
like that
let's talk about that for a second
because our music um which which we we
love and have been using from day one
we've never um like we've never had the
money to license it and keep it ours
like to write music and then to have it
be like owned by the show
so there's a company that owns this
library and they just license it out to
anybody and everybody yeah so like there
was a year where madden the madden
football game the sunny theme was there
was the madden theme and right now on
minecraft i hear i hear sunny music in
the background of my house i'm like
what's going on like my kids watching
sonny it they're it's on my minecraft
videos they're using sunny music on
minecraft videos
yeah and it's a very heavily used
casting commercial you hear in
commercials all the time yeah it used to
upset me because i'd be like oh man dang
it why didn't we just like have a theme
song that was just hours you know
but i think maybe it ended up working in
our favor because it trick like every
time those songs play people think of
sunny eventually yeah
eventually that happened and
advertising
it's like if there's an association with
the show yeah but like madden is way
bigger than sunny so people
madden like the purse company like what
are you talking about the shoe guys
[Laughter]
what are you talking about no you're
absolutely right that game's way bigger
than this yeah so people will be like oh
that's the music item i don't know but
it was always funny to me that like look
like look around all the shows that you
watch
and know
you're like oh no they didn't use that
theme song on a on a tied commercial no
ours is the only one yeah the only one
where they're like oh cheers well
literally they they now are using the
cheers song yeah what did i see that
that must have cost them a fortune
seriously to pay paramount a fortune who
wrote that theme song
song to cheers
that's a good theme song it's the golden
girls really amazing it's incredible and
that guy was like it was he was just
like a pop artist yeah and his version
of it is strange like the woman singing
it is a much
cooler gary portnoy
gary portnoy is cheers is cheers is he
also golden girls
he might be
it might be the same guy or maybe it's
andrew
younger
um i don't think so
wait a second pop guy yeah so you're
saying the guy who did the golden girls
theme song he has a version his version
of that song
yeah well it's him
thank you for being a friend thank you
for being andrew gold andrew gold it's
it's in his name
yeah that's crazy yeah okay it took him
about an hour to write yeah
it always does it always does um now
that was the
because i cocaine i told you guys this
this story before but um there was a
time where i sat next to uh the drummer
for uh the band's survivor on on on a
flight right and i got to chatting with
this guy super nice guy looked like one
of those guys was like oh you're still
rocking like the 80s hair band look
but you're like in your late 50s you
know but whatever anyway the guy was
super nice and uh he actually told me
the
story of how he how
the band survivor wrote the song eye of
the tiger
for uh rocky
iii i believe it was yeah
so
uh stallone had actually called the lead
singer of survivor uh and left him a
voicemail and uh he was like you know
beep
this is uh this is sliced alone
and uh i really like music
that i'd love for you to write the theme
song to the new rocky movie that i'm
doing right so this guy gets the message
uh gets the voicemail and he's like i
asked my buddy like [ __ ] with me you
know what i mean so he doesn't he pays
no attention to it gets a call gets
another voicemail like couple weeks
later
what's going on you know this it sliced
the law i really want to use you know
it doesn't know i feel like this
collaboration could be a real knockout
[Laughter]
um and so
but again he just thinks it's like you
know his friend's like [ __ ] with him
so he doesn't he doesn't call the guy
back
um
then he gets a call from his agent his
agent's like dude what are you doing you
know or his booking agent or manager or
whoever he's like sly stallone is like
trying to get in touch with you wants
you guys to write the new theme song
he's like oh [ __ ] that's real
so so then he gets on the phone with
stallone still loans like you know
basically tells him uh i i i need a
theme song for my for rocky iii i think
you guys are perfect for it i'd like for
you guys to write one but here's what i
need i need you to write two songs
because you know what if i like one over
the other i i need you to write two
songs we'll pay you to write two songs
so these guys get in the studio they
spent about two weeks
crafting the most epic
song ever right
and then they get to the very end of it
they realize like two o'clock in the
morning and they've got to turn in both
songs the next day to to sliced alone
and
listen when you tell sly stallone you're
you know you're hitting a deadline you
better hit it because sly is going to
come after you you know what i mean um
with the expendables
[Laughter]
uh
so they they realize they're like oh
[ __ ] we have to write like a second song
they're like oh we'll just bang
something out real quick and over the
course of the next like hour or so
they just like
wrote i have a tiger and just did either
time like an hour or like two hours and
they're like all right let's go to bed
that's at least we'll give them two but
clearly the other one is better he
played and of course you know you know
the rest of that is they played either
uh both the songs and and sly loved eye
the tiger and they were like what we
were just [ __ ] around like that was
you know
and then the other song he ended up
using i believe in the movie fist
fist yeah he did a movie called fist
yeah i think so
i i think so yeah yeah man like the
theme
yeah what was that about i'm nervous
yeah don't
don't google that um
it's an acronym f-i-s-t yeah it was an
accurate yeah a neo-noir crime drama
weird yeah so i believe he used that
other survivor song in the movie
fist you know what that's what song that
was uh i don't know actually i don't
know anyway the guy from survivor was
very nice the drummer i liked him he was
he told some good stories that's the
only one i remember uh do you want to
tell one of the good ones
listen man he's on a lot of pain come on
man i'm on a lot of pain pills right now
i'm not thinking straight yeah what do
you got yeah what do you got tell us a
good story um
i i am curious to know
uh
like if you guys
i know you you got you've you've done
acid before
right
do you not want to talk about this no
yeah
okay have you done acids yes you did
acid uh-huh when did you do acid like
right like right after high school just
once
you did it we've done it twice yeah okay
when what were the circumstances and do
you have any funny stories surrounding
that because yeah it's a fun dream no
what uh what was the name of the why am
i blanking on the name of the um music
series that was big when we were
lollapalooza oh yeah music series
well my mind went to coachella and i
couldn't get it out of my head yeah la
la palooza
yeah i did some did some acid
lalalapalooza yeah is that fun what year
no no
uh the
1996. 96
it was the beastie boys no that was 94.
oh so i was in high school that was 94
because uh i was at that lollapalooza
probably not the same one i went i went
to the one in in atlanta oh yeah i don't
think you came to philly no no
uh yeah no i mean i it's just not for me
no it's not i might maybe try it again
later when my kids are older and i can
get in like i want to break through the
matrix and see what's on the other side
kind of thing you know what i mean i
think i want to go on a guided one at
this point right like i want to see the
destruction of my ego before my very
eyes yes i don't want to just you know
take like three tabs of acid and drink
16 course lights and then you know throw
up well you were also probably like yeah
you're fighting it you know what i mean
like when it kicks in you gotta lean
into it you know when you start fighting
it you know that's when the fear kicks
off yeah yeah when the fear gets in then
you fight in the field for absolutely 13
15 hours
how much it took but yeah yeah or years
yeah unfortunately i think you had
you've had some good
trips yeah yeah yeah yeah but and some
bad like uh
i ate too many mushrooms once at a
fish concert in 90
six you're into a fish concert oh yeah
but he was you were a big fan what we
were at the clifford ball he was a jam
band guy oh yeah i was there with uh me
and my pals and uh
oh man it's so like
we were so low rent like we went with
this other group of kids and they like
they were like kind of rich kids they
had a volvo they had like a nice like
tent and [ __ ] we had like a tarp
and then we were like hey we're gonna
try to make a little tent out of this
tarp can we use your frying pan
they were like making like pancakes and
[ __ ] and we like [ __ ]
totally [ __ ] this kid's frying pan up
trying to like hammer hammer and spike
we didn't mean to like i'm so sorry dude
i ruined you nice frying pan um and then
we got our hands on like an
extraordinary amount of very powerful
mushrooms and ate way too many of them i
remember
i remember passing out like within the
first five minutes
throwing up
and then like when i came to i was
already tripping a thousand times harder
than i already had and this was within
the first 30 minutes so i was like okay
this is going to be quite a ride and i
remember just trying to like hang on to
my sanity for my dear life look at one
point we're in the concert you know and
uh we're just kind of like sitting on
the lawn and
all of a sudden like
everyone
turns around they're looking like right
at us oof and we're like that's you
don't want you why is this happening
what the [ __ ] is happening
only to realize there's like a
marching band like moving
oh we don't realize what's going on i
remember another one of my buddies said
like he's like man the cutest girl came
up to you and asked you for a cigarette
and all you said was like yeah i'm all
about it yeah i'm all about it
you know
but
mostly it was good and then
i don't know i think i would do it again
once i got through this parenting phase
in my life and like yeah i didn't i
would hate for the fear to kick in and
be like oh [ __ ] i'm
i've compromised my brain and i got a
kid out there but i do think
i don't know i think it's like something
everyone should do a little bit of i
kind of do too actually i think under
the right circumstances i think it's uh
it can be a very very eye-opening
experience i mean like
you've done ayahuasca you've done a lot
of psychedelics right
um yeah uh i know
you had to think about that which is
interesting well no because well because
it's because i haven't done like an
ayahuasca ceremony i i did a ceremony
with uh a shaman and a bunch of other
people and uh took
something that was it was actually a
combination of ayahuasca and uh and
psilocybin so
uh but it wasn't like a super high dose
so i wasn't like tripping balls because
it was my first but weren't you doing
one of those things which sounds awesome
and also disgusting and terrible at the
same time where you were like [ __ ]
in a bucket and then throwing up and
then also oh you wasn't one of those no
because i know people have gone through
that we're like nah man it's awesome you
go through like this guided tour in your
house and like you [ __ ] your brains out
but you got a bucket so you do under the
bucket then you also vomit i'm like okay
where's the good part it's very
spiritual
it's super spiritually like you really
like see you know what's inside of you
yeah because it's now in a bucket
[Music]
rum
charlie
i don't
feel creatively good about the ep the
episode where we talk about invincible i
feel creatively good about the episode
that aired in
2002 or whatever that was yeah but i
don't like i felt like the podcast
version wasn't we we didn't
we got we got about halfway i was
listening to a little bit of it and i
just don't think it was very good i
think it was boring
and i want to blame it on glenn well no
that's not true i don't want to blame it
on glenn i want to blame it on glenn's
um
busted collarbone well yeah i mean i i i
want to um i got three options right i
can blame it on me i don't want to do
that no i can blame it on you but you're
here i'm here yeah um but glenn has left
and he's not here so i could blame it on
glenn yeah glenn's not here i think we
should blame it on glenn and to be a
good friend i could say well he was on
pain meds for his broken collarbone so
we could blame it on that yeah i think
that's i think that's i think that's
fair so here we are and it's a different
day and we're wearing different clothes
and we're talking about the thing that
we weren't talking about but most
importantly glenn isn't here just to be
clear for the people who aren't
watching this john's not here he has a
thing he can't even be here so we're
gonna have somebody uh who's gonna call
in who's going to take his place
well we're getting a call we're getting
a call are we getting a call
yes
all right welcome to the always sunny
podcast you're on with rob and charlie
hello
hello
well here's the thing special caller so
we were talking about this uh episode
the gang gets invincible it's one where
uh the gang tries out for the
philadelphia eagles that happened in
season three
and uh we just we we didn't do a good
job the podcast wasn't funny now we've
gotten rid of glenn he's he's
he had to go somewhere he couldn't stick
around but we thought we'd take this
special call
you mm-hmm i really i really appreciate
it um
i'm happy your voice is that is so loud
can you turn her down in my headphones
is that not so shrieky in your ears
you guys do you want me to come in
because no very last minute
i'm happy to come in i hear that you're
recording now so how far are you that
way
are you close back
i don't know where you are and i'm not
really coming in
that was just meant to be funny i don't
have any plans to pop by um
guys this is really smart i feel good it
feels very last minute but i'll still
i'll take it i'll take advantage of it
let's tell the listener at home or the
watcher uh in their in their probably
home or office uh who we have on the
line here if you if you haven't guessed
the voice
and i and i have it and i haven't who is
this
you guys it's the star of the of your
television show uh the only woman the
the one and only
uh the big bird herself and um
i'm here and i'm happy to be here it
does feel like a bit of an afterthought
but that's okay i'll let it go i've been
waiting a long time for this thank you
for having me it is most definitely an
afterthought
television's katelyn olsen people
televisions
hey kaitlyn do you remember being in
this episode do you remember being in
the show at all
i remember i remember moments listen
this is the episode where uh i dressed
up what was my name cole call cool
and as soon as we got me all dressed up
i turned around and looked in the mirror
and i was like oh you've made me look
like david hornsby yes yeah you you did
come across looking like
cricket for the for the people at home
who don't know him
by the first name um yeah something
happens when you put a goatee uh on me
and um
take away my hair i look exactly like
david horn
well one of the good things about having
you on for the for for the first time is
maybe we could even go back to the
beginning of the show we don't have to
talk about invincible we could talk
about the beginning what was your
experience uh auditioning for the show
because i think the first few episodes
that we got some good feedback that
people like to hear some of those
stories from the beginning
yeah the first few episodes were
stinkers for me because you guys had
already written them
um and you did a great job of writing uh
for your characters which is why i
wanted to do the show in the first place
because it was so well written um but
not such a great job for dee cause she
was kind of um
a wet blanket there was a lot of like
you guys
you gotta stop having fun
yeah we covered all this now some now
listen we covered this on the podcast
but you don't listen to the bot i know
but you don't listen to the podcast
you don't support me you don't support
me what about the first what about the
very first time you came into the
audition room uh what do you remember
from that experience did you you've been
do you even remember rob in the room
no so what i do remember is as soon as i
got in my car i called my manager
because i thought it was such a good i
wanted it so bad and i was like i think
that was really good and she goes were
any of them cute and i was like not
really
[Laughter]
good good
it was not love at first sight i really
fell in love with rob's ego i think
during the first season yeah
a lot of confidence in that mcelhenny he
was in control yeah yeah i felt safe you
know what i mean like somebody was in
charge and funny so
yeah i'm not too attractive now i am now
i find him very handsome
it only took 17 years yeah really to get
to that place it's a long time it's a
long time but i walked into the room and
i
instantly all of you were in there
and you were all
participating and laughing and like just
having fun and encouraging me to have
fun with it and i remember thinking this
is the best audition experience ever
because they usually are
absolutely terrible
i think a lot a lot of that had to do
with the fact that we were we're actors
and we and we were compassionate to how
shitty that situation normally is and
then also you were awesome so it was
really fun yeah we were laughing because
you were funny yeah oh you're sweet i
was having fun and then i remember rob
saying
um
okay just put the script down and just
improvise with to have this do the scene
with charlie but just you guys say
whatever you want and that was like why
it was super fun
are you calling us
are you in your car
yeah where are you i'm outside oh you're
outside are you really are you pulled
over talking to us or are you like on
route
i'm on route i'm driving i'm being safe
are you worried about my safety i'm
being very safe charlie what's what is
this yeah where were you headed tell us
about yourself try to paint the picture
yeah you know you're trying to get the
big picture here for the people at home
like like let's get them all the
information i took one son to school she
took the other
and then
then what happened i came to work no i
don't know where you went are you going
to go to the beach for pleasure or for
business
um today i dropped off one son i stopped
and got the coffee and then i went and
got a facial oh there you go okay
yeah yeah you gotta take care of that
face i got a facial and um now i'm on my
way to uh have lunch with a friend and
then i have a doctor appointment in the
afternoon and then i'm going to pick up
both boys this is great
thank you now i know i understand this
guy we're your schedule here this is
really good is there anything you want
to promote or rob do you get worried are
you are you at the jealous type are you
like now now who's the friend she's
having lunch with and is it the same
person who gave her the facial and
what's happening here like
and you kind of face
yeah exactly like do you you don't have
a jealous bone in your body right
i i i don't think so caitlyn can speak
to that i don't really no i don't know
i'm being blue-collar well because
caitlyn uh well because caitlyn had a
had a sex scene in a movie she just shot
oh yeah yes
yeah i i i had a sex scene with woody
harrelson um
in the movie i told him all about it in
great detail and he was like cool cool i
gotta go
yeah well because it because you had a
sex scene with woody harrelson he wasn't
you know like
if you had a sex scene with brad pitt he
would have been like now hang on a
second well did you see that sex scene
with woody harrelson and um true
detective i mean that was were you
saying
look i'm not saying woody harrelson is
not a sexy man but i'm just saying
you're probably the very attractive man
yeah yeah a long time vegan
long time vegan
this is just the information i know
caitlin i'm just trying to fill the air
time here
i see no well here's a fun fact about
rob that probably i think most people
know he's very good friends with
jack shepherd who is sort of an ex an ex
lover of mine
he did not know that i'm not sort of i
didn't know that hardcore lovers i did
not know that it was pretty hardcore i
was trying to be i was trying to you
know be nice but um yeah no rob and
jack's a really good friend you like men
with masculinity inferiority complexes
it is so interesting men who appear to
be confident but are masking severe and
secure they're trying to prove so hard
that they're a man yes
exactly but then perfectly open to talk
about it with other men that's the
exciting part that's the missing piece
so they have
both hard and soft you might say yeah
not too hard not too small not too hard
not too small boys two men they become
men yeah uh caitlyn do you is there
anything about doing this episode of
your do you remember being in philly
when we were
shooting and that was like fred savage
directing days and him like just
partying like a maniac
and we had we had good times in philly i
believe did fred get he was not arrested
because it wasn't he didn't do anything
crazy but he i think he was pulled over
by the police or the driver was pulled
over by the police
because fred was hanging out the window
or or the roof i think he just got
yelled out
i don't know it was fred's limo he
climbed out the top of it while it was
while it was in transit and was like
climbing on the back of the car
there's something that happens in
philadelphia where everyone kind of
loses their minds and does things maybe
they wouldn't do at home that's what i
remember about shooting yeah this is 12
years
i do remember season one
filming in philly and going to just the
bar in the
hotel we were in
uh and meeting your buddy you had
somebody who
another guy she's another guy that you
probably used today
that's that would be uh ian right
yeah yeah
my college boyfriend and we were
drinking a lot of yinglings
and but i don't think you guys weren't
together yet right
no not season one no no um
no is it
is it fun going to philly or is it a
little bit stressful because you've got
to like deal with rob's family the whole
time
and you've got to be on
we don't actually see his family that
much when we go because such a whirlwind
um i love going to philly philly's got
great restaurants and great people and
all rob's friends from high school are
there and i love it we only stopped
going regularly because we started
having kids right it just became a
little bit too much of a nightmare
and because rob would go on talk shows
and tell people where we were filming
and we would get so swarmed that it felt
downright dangerous
we were like yeah remember
the last time we were there we were in a
van and people were uh
the van was dry moving we were driving
and people were um pounding on the
windows and trying to pass like pieces
of paper in for us to sign we were like
someone's gonna get run over this is
and then some random man showed me his
penis and offered me a beer
that sounds sounds like sounds about
right yeah
one or the other dog both of them no
this is why ron's not jealous because
it's non-stop harassment for you and he
just he has to deal with it so much yeah
i mean
was that random man can we talk about it
was it danny
can we talk about the panels
you didn't want to out there
hey caitlyn you want to bear up some
fell out
okay so what's your favorite episode oh
my god oh boy what a stupid question
don't answer that i don't answer it tell
me what you're doing man what's your
favorite episode that's the worst and
that's you're not you know that's the
worst it's the worst
i have moments i love when charlie and i
get to uh pair up and do things you know
we thought we were human we were just
talking about this that you and i have
not i feel like we don't have enough of
those things and they're always so fun
and funny and we don't get to do it
enough i think next season we gotta yeah
i feel like maybe that's why they're
some of my favorite is because it just
doesn't happen that often but
um those are always really fun i don't
know i just like when
i mean i i love things like you guys
drowning me in a bog almost so you know
anything that's like crazy those are
just stuff
you you were a trooper to get in that
bog that was uh
nasty
gross stuff and yeah and you fully
submerged that much of a trooper
whatever please i'm doing it because i
know it's gonna be hilarious it's very
selfish of me
yeah you climb
climbing over mary elizabeth was really
[ __ ] funny
oh man now you were pregnant through a
lot of this this show
right i mean we did a whole season where
you were eight months pregnant what's
that like yeah so the p diddy the p
diddy boat dance with the inflatable guy
that kind of got
kind of blew up and got famous i was i
just remember being angry the whole time
first of all we were in long beach and
it wasn't like two o'clock in the
morning it was and it was cold yeah
and i was um i was so hell-bent on on
moving my body with the way that that
thing was moving and i was pissed off
because secretly i was six months
pregnant and i couldn't bend backwards
as far as i wanted to and like snap
myself back up
and i threw the whole time just being
angry like this isn't working this isn't
working my stupid baby in there it's
ruining everything yeah um this is all
tracking
this is all tracking it's sort of like
when um
for the viewer and listener out there
who doesn't know that when when caitlyn
and one of my favorite moments of the of
the show
uh
she leaves the shoes sales uh or the
shoe store and she falls into the car
and she bangs her head that is her and
that's a real car and a real dent and
she said i'm doing this yeah not only
that and then you did one take it was
amazing we were like oh my god she broke
her neck
but you were okay
you were okay and then we said look
don't do another take we'll get one for
safety we'll have the stunt person do it
she's here to do it
and
she did the stunt woman didn't do it
half as good as you did it no because
she did it safely because some person's
like yeah if you do it the way caitlyn
does it i'm gonna break my neck yeah you
could be paralyzed yes
well listen she i i was angry because
she was not funny and she wasn't gonna
flail her body in a funny way and i
needed i needed you guys to give me a
chance and i knew i only had one chance
so i just really went for it
yeah um there's a lot of chiropractic
after that but it was totally worth it
how many bones have you broken over the
course of the run of this i'm gonna let
husband and wife talk for a second
because caitlyn i have to i can't hold
my p i've been holding my pee for so
long okay charlie's gonna go play back
okay all right
yeah you gotta take care of your kidneys
when you gotta pee just let it go i get
it listen to that podcast listen listen
he's gone he's got he's he's gone now
listen i this is what i've always wanted
i want the podcast to just be me right
and i guess you can call him from time
to
time
megan but megan won't say a goddamn
thing back there
right now it's the three of us hi
caitlyn
hi maggie
hey can i ask you a question
yes please do you remember rob peeing on
you in philly when he got too drunk
that night
no
what oh wait and was it was it philly or
new york
it was philly
oh yes this is when we were secretly
wait
please yes i do we were secretly dating
and you got so drunk we all went out to
dinner you even you guys even went out
after that i went back to my room
and you came like drunkenly knocking on
my
[Laughter]
the bed was soaked and you tried to say
you had sweat
it was the opposite it was the opposite
you were like man you really sweat a lot
and i was like yeah i guess i did so
while he's back he's back
yeah
i didn't
cut the [ __ ] i know it was not
you peed me and you were like no i just
i swipe dump sweat sometimes i'm like
that would have come from all over your
body not just by your penis
oh you're talking about when rob pissed
into bed yes was this the episode we
were talking about it okay so yeah oh it
was this episode that we were talking
about uh it was actually no the one
before but then i think you brought it
up again yeah well yeah let me reiterate
i've never listened to your podcast i
know
i know but but you don't watch the show
you don't really watch episodes of the
show right i mean no i
i love watching episodes of the show
there were there was a period of like
four or five years where you didn't want
to watch it because you were in the
editing room so much
um and so
we didn't sit down and watch them
together but i see of course i've seen
every episode i i i even like them i
know this sounds
weird but like if it'll just randomly
come on somewhere i get sucked in i
think they're hilarious because i also
don't remember we've done so many of
them and
that's we often break up into a and b
stories i don't always remember what
happens in the episode besides what i
was doing
i'm finding how much i've forgotten too
and i thought i knew them all like the
back of my hand just because of the
amount of time we spent in the editing
room
but uh it's interesting going back
watching all these caitlyn from day one
you're great on the show
thank you charlie rob gets a lot better
but you from guys it took me a while to
warm into it caitlyn and katelyn i was
learning from the masters i was learning
from people like caitlin and charlotte
they just needed to get fat that's
awesome
suddenly you were hilarious no i think
you're funny in those first seasons too
you don't you just don't think it which
is why we lean into it
bob's weird he thinks he's not funny or
like the least funny of all of us and
that's so stupid i know that's why we
lean and we we
we see that wound and we jump right on
it you know
i think it's objectively true i think
it's objective but i'm a lover of comedy
and i can see that you guys are
funnier than me and i'm okay with that
well that's that you're right that's
true i i'm funnier than you but
that's true yeah you're very hard
i need something yeah smart guy
um
well i guess we run out of things i mean
caitlin thanks for calling in
are you where you have to be
are you i'm i'm
you know what thanks for thanks for
making my ride more fun i'm about five
minutes away um when do you guys want me
to come in because it'd be fun it'd be
so fun
megan let's get her off the line yeah
let's go ahead and cut this call okay
okay
okay sweetie
sorry you're breaking up we're making
the connection here you're driving
connection
well that was fun
yeah i mean it's not it's better it's
better with glenn yeah yeah yeah it's
it's just you know he was just low
energy for that one episode but you
don't want to deal with it you know why
because caitlyn's nice and happy glenn's
angry and it's and it's really
interesting and that's when it's fun but
when he's all low energy because he's
like my back and my browns are broken
i
that would be more interesting than just
sitting there just low energy
come on man and look i'm not going to
blame them
he was on massive amounts of some kind
of downer i'm on drugs when i can't make
a podcast interesting
but i think we can both agree it is
better with glenn than it would be with
caitlin oh i mean
[Music]